perfect alright i'm morgan Cundiff i'm a
data scientist as a company called shop
runner my pronouns are she hers and
today I'm going to talk about developing
data science to add a business value so
it's not gonna be a super technical talk
but I will step through a computer
vision project just to go into examples
about what I learned about developing
specifically to add business value so oh
I can't go to the next time first of all
why do we want to do this a lot of data
science projects especially in research
set up to develop new techniques and new
models and really innovate on the
systems that we use so why would we want
to restructure an entire project
specifically around adding business
value so first off I'm really operating
under the assumption that we all enjoy
being part of data science projects and
enjoy the challenge that goes into
building them and creating them but also
we want to make an impact right and we
want to use those insights or those
predictions that we make and really make
an impact on what we're doing and the
business that we're working with and
that brings us to this statistic which
is only 13% of data science projects
actually make it into production this is
a really low number right so if we are
spending all our time building these new
challenges building these new models no
matter how amazing they are and no
matter how great they work or how
effective they are or how innovative it
is if we're never making it into
production they're really not having the
impact that we wanted them to on the
business or on the cause that we're
focusing on right so this is also true
from the company side so this is a quote
from Deborah luff the CTO of data
science and AI at IBM who said if your
competitors are applying AI and they're
finding insight that allows them to
accelerate they're going to peel away
really really quickly so this is just
generate this demonstrates how crucial
it is for data science projects to move
forward right a lot of companies spend a
huge amount of rete of resources whether
it's time or money on data science
projects and data science people so if
those are never adding business value
that can seem like a lot of wasted
resources it also means that if they're
never making an impact they're never
seeing that benefit right and so their
competitors are going to move away
they're not going to be able to innovate
as fast I can really ding the company
over all plus a lot of us in this room I
guessing our data scientists or support
data science projects so if we can never
use those projects to add business value
or gonna have a hard time justifying our
jobs in the future so hopefully that's a
little bit of a motivator so what are
the obstacles we face to doing this
what's blocking us from doing this and
why is it so hard first off a lot of
data science is a scene a little bit
like magic right there's a real lack of
understanding of exactly how our
projects work how are they how is
software engineering or other types of
Technic from data science what really
goes into a data science project and how
that works
so I think we face a lot of problems
where we're trying to justify why we
need certain types of data well we need
that to be clean and not everyone quite
understands how that works what they can
request of us or why that needs to
happen so this means you know people
don't even understand how to use our
projects once it's done so you spent all
this time making this amazing model or
building off this feature and then
someone doesn't know how to use it and
you're stuck like justifying this
project that they don't understand and
haven't been a part of also these same
people face tons of competing priorities
right so whether they're engineers or
their product people they likely have
these really busy roadmaps and a lot of
their own work that they want to focus
on and build towards and so they don't
almost have this time to budget to focus
on your projects whether that's getting
them into the production or even just
using them once they're already in
production so especially since data
science can have a really long
development cycles right so a lot of
data science right now is very
experimental we might have to start off
a lot of research a lot of development
our first try might always work so when
we have these super long development
cycles it's really difficult to keep
people engaged so I think a lot of these
talks focus on how to get data science
people excite or how to get other people
excited and data science projects from
the very beginning and while that's
super important and really crucial it is
not the full story right so if you get
someone excited and then the data
scientist go off on their own
and develop for four months six months
however long it is when you come back
you're not necessarily on that personal
roadmap
anymore you're no longer a priority and
they may have moved on so it's really
important that throughout this entire
cycle we'd be keeping people updated
keeping them informed about the project
they truly know what's going on
all right so Who am I and why am I
talking about this I have a kind of
interesting background
I studied by automatics in undergrad and
actually worked as a biologist studying
Alzheimer's and diabetes so these images
here are of corneal nerves so different
level layers in the eye and as anyone
who's done research knows I have looked
at these way too long so if you've ever
been in a lab she spent way too much
time looking at your data and so while I
was working there we didn't have a lot
of technical support and we had to get
technical support from outside so I had
a lot of experience having no technical
background being a biologist and working
with the other side and trying to
communicate so a lot of times we would
get projects that we had had no input in
we didn't fully understand they were
expected to use and then trying to
integrate that and trying to budget our
time of how we're gonna use this is a
huge deal so that risk factor right of
getting a project that you don't
necessarily know you need you don't know
if it's gonna work for you you don't
know what went into it and now you have
to put aside your own work in order to
figure that out and how you're going to
use it and so I learned a lot through
that experience of exactly what needs to
go into that communication but also the
other way around of how hard it can be
when you are the subject matter expert
trying to communicate what you need to
technologists when you don't understand
what they can build and how they can
build it and how that can be really
difficult if you've never seen the
project you don't understand how it
works how do you communicate what
features you need or even how those
features should be structured so I then
moved on and was a software engineer at
a phone serve a company called Digium
this is actually one of the phones that
I worked on wall there I know not a lot
of people see desk phones anymore so
it's a little outdated most of the work
I did do there was on mobile development
so a little different but this was also
a really fun project too since I don't
think many people get to use desk phones
anymore I did learn a lot there
s'alright keep taking this microphone I
did learn a lot there about the
differences between software engineering
and data science so I think in software
engineering sometimes you know it's a
lot easier to do things like demonstrate
partway through a project and the things
that come easier about working with
other teams when they can see it when
they know what's going on when they've
used a phone app before and they know
exactly what that looks like and so I
think while those processes tend to be
very different I have learned a lot
about what is important about that and
working with other teams and how to
bring that into data science even if we
don't get those some of the things for
free all right I now work for a company
called shop runner that bills itself as
the Amazon for the other half of the
Internet so we partner with a bunch of
brands including Saks Fifth Avenue
Bloomingdale's Tory Burch Neiman Marcus
and about 130 other retailers to bring
all of our members free two-day shipping
free returns Express Checkout a bunch of
other member benefits on all of our
retail partner sites so while there I
work on a project called Phoenix and
it's called that for a couple of reasons
before I get into exactly what it is so
our data science team decided before I
started that all of our projects were
going to be named after Harry Potter
themes so that's why you see the Harry
Potter picture before also because it's
bright and colorful and Phoenix is about
color so you'll see that a little more
in the future but also because it was a
pretty experimental project and I knew
we were going to keep iterating on it
and it was going to keep coming back
again and again so you'll see that as a
theme throughout the rest of the talk is
really about how we brought it back and
how we iterated on it and how you know
each time we got feedback good or bad we
just iterated move forward and it kept
coming back over and over alright so now
I've explained the name which as we all
know is half the battle starting a new
project in tech naming things and so
what actually is Phoenix so that idea of
Phoenix is color identification so here
we have an example of a product image
from our retail partner
and maybe we want to get an RGB value
out of that this is the corresponding
color swatch and then maybe we want a
specific name for that color so why do
we want to do this in house so the data
we get from retailers on color products
is often pretty messy a lot of times
they don't send us color at all
sometimes they do send us color but it's
wrong and then even when those colors
are right each of our retail partners
can have a different set of color names
right so if we want to do something like
take a product from one brand and show
it on a particular retail site maybe
that color name that we get for that
brand doesn't match a color the retailer
has so we want to be able to in-house
take in those products give them all
you know names or at least RGB values
that everyone can use and then pass them
forward okay oh okay so this is an
example again of when we have multiple
colors in an image so this can be like
are in a product so you be slightly more
difficult but a lot of times when we get
those colors from retailers we just are
getting a single color but we also want
to be able to filter from multiple
colors as well right so someone looking
for this address the primary color might
be this play Oh blue but they might also
search for something that was yellow or
this pale pink and we want to see all of
those colors that are in the product and
not just one that's given to us by a
retailer or one that we detect all right
so how should we start developing right
so I think this is a big point of the
talk and get into it so we'll start with
a few examples but start off with
something I think most people already do
right so the beginning of a project you
get a bunch of people into a room you
want to talk about what is this probably
gonna do how are you gonna build it and
so at some places this is like mostly
data scientists and engineers but I
think a lot of places do a pretty good
job now of also having product people in
the room right
also having people who are gonna use the
product whoever your stakeholders are
and I think that's crucially important
to have this conversation with everyone
so that you're fully understanding what
are our goals for the project what are
their goals for the project is this
really going to be usable what's going
to happen with this right I think where
some people fall short and a lot of my
previous companies has often foolish
fallen short is that afterwards we kind
of go our separate ways
and isolate ourselves the data
scientists go work on their project the
software engineers go work on it
whatever it happens to be and then we
lose touch so I'm suggesting as part of
this new set up to a project is that we
also set up like a reoccurring time for
all those people to get back into a room
and have a conversation so this could be
once a month this could be every couple
weeks this could be you one once a
quarter whatever you have time for but
really putting it on the calendar at the
beginning of the project and setting
that up as a recurring meeting and we
want to do this at the beginning for a
couple of reasons it's a time where
we're going to stop developing and move
towards how are we going to display this
project and how are we going to discuss
it right and so we have that deadline of
when we're gonna do that when we're
gonna stop this current iteration and
move towards how are we going to talk
about it it's also the point is to be
showing them not necessarily a completed
project right so maybe we have this
meeting once a month maybe we have it
every two weeks and in those two weeks
we haven't made a new product but we
still want to demonstrate the value add
that we've had in those two weeks or
that one month or however long the
iteration is so this is not necessarily
a time to get together and demonstrate a
finished product but give an update on
where the project is right and so this
also continually reminds our
stakeholders and everyone involved what
the project is what the priority is that
it's a project that is still moving
forward and also lets them give feedback
right if they have new ideas on what
we've said so the side effect of this
also is that our stakeholders become
more comfortable with us they become
more comfortable with what we do and
what the project is and so when they
have questions when they have feature
requests when there's an issue they feel
more comfortable coming forward and
telling us about this all right so now
we've set up the project now we want to
move into this like iterative
development cycle that I've been talking
about so there's a couple of steps here
primarily we want to focus on the use
case so hopefully we already have this
overall use case for the entire project
that we discussed at that initial
meeting and then each iteration we want
to decide how are we going to move
closer and closer to that goal and this
can be
so a little different when we're
focusing on specifically building
business value right especially or some
teams especially those who focus on
research and development go into a
project to develop a new model and then
try and justify that use case afterwards
and then end up having to convince
people how to use their project so we
really want to do in this iteration is
focus on exactly what we're going to add
and get closer to that use case so
there's a couple ways that you get
trapped in this what I want to talk
about this idea of diminishing returns
so I think most technical projects face
this right and it's the idea of you put
in a certain amount of effort and the
more effort you put in the slower and
slower your your accruing rewards right
so maybe at the beginning it's really
easy to see a huge return but then as
you move further and further along you
end up having to put in more and more
time to see that same return and this
can happen with time so say you have a
project and you are really trying to
make it faster and make a more efficient
decrease the amount of time it takes
right at the beginning maybe it doesn't
take that much effort maybe there's a
lot of code cleanup that we can do to
make it a lot faster but to add a
certain point it gets harder and harder
to shave off time right we've shaved off
as much as maybe we can or we know how
to and that gets harder and harder we
have to put in more effort to shave off
time this can also happen with metrics
right so precision and recall or maybe
coverage whatever you're measuring at
the beginning that could be really hard
to are really easy to increase coverage
right maybe there's an edge case we
haven't tried maybe we can add a bit
more data and that hugely increases our
coverage of ever training data but then
as we get higher and higher closer to
100% it gets really difficult to
increase our coverage I think that when
we're focusing specifically on how to
add business value we have a whole
nother layer of diminishing returns on
top of that right so not only do we have
to decrease time and decrease and
increase our metrics but we also have to
think about the customer so maybe it
takes us more effort to decrease time
but then that decrease time might not
affect our end
so what we really want to be thinking
about is at the end of this I don't want
to come forward and say like oh I
decreased my model by 0.002 seconds when
our model only runs overnight once a
month and I think that happens a lot in
research where we get to focus on these
incremental time increases or
incremental metrics increases when at
the end of the day that might not make a
difference to a customer and maybe it
does maybe you you know you're losing
customers because it takes too much time
for your request to finish and then that
is the value add that you're going to
keep customers because they're not upset
about how long your loading time is and
not necessarily just the fact that your
model takes point zero two seconds to
finish so at the end of the day that's
really what we want to focus on here is
what is our value add going to be and
how are we going to explain at the end
the benefit to the user and not just we
made our model faster or we made it more
effective we're really focusing on that
end use case and bringing it back to how
are we going to explain to other teams
the benefit that they are really going
to see so in this particular project I'm
gonna focus on this use case of say we
have this initial seed item and we want
to be able to recommend similar colors
of items so maybe we have a user who's
browsing a page and they look for this
dress they can't find it it's not in
their size or we just want to show them
other things and we want to show them
these similar recommendations in a
specific color all right so the next
step is that we want to start as simple
as possible so what do we mean by as
simple as possible it doesn't
necessarily mean the simplest code
possible this is really talking about
like an MVP and I think when some people
hear that as was said in the talk
yesterday some people think like oh let
me just get one feature out one small
piece but what we really want to focus
on is what is the simplest way that we
can create a full system that's going to
demonstrate that value at rate so rather
than like the top trying to hit every
feature or every option and making it
perfect what's the way that we can say
we
started here we're now here and look at
the increased value in between so what
is the simplest way that we can go from
point A to point B and show that value
ad right so in this specific example are
V one of the color or shop owners like V
one of this color model was actually a
deep learning model that could
categorize products into these 13
different colors right so deep learning
model that doesn't scream simple but the
idea was that it was pretty robust we
could get metrics back on it it was
pretty reliable that it was going to
work and we had people who had worked on
similar things before who could get that
up and running right and that doesn't
necessarily hit all of our features
right we only have these 13 different
colors anyone who works in machine
learning before know that once we train
up a model on these 13 colors it's not
trivial to add a new color to take one
out to make them more specific right
we'd have to go back and retrain the
whole model but what we do have is a way
to take in a product and give back a
specific color and we can then show that
to our users they can play with it they
can use it they can see that value add
of giving users recommendations based on
that certain color or filtering out
items for a specific color so like I
said it doesn't have all of our features
right these are the two of the buckets
these are a bunch of products that were
categorized as yellow a bunch of
products that were categorized as blue
you can see here I mean we have an item
in this book in the bottom here this
dress is kind of white with yellow print
and that cannot go in both the white and
yellow bucket right this is a single
label problem so it has to go in one or
the other we also have you know a bunch
of different blues in here like these
are completely different shades of blue
we have no way to differentiate between
one or the other so we really have to
move forward and iterate next time but
we have a stable robust system that
people can see and people can use so
right now we have something like this
right we have this seed item we have a
bunch of green or recommendations that
we can show users and that is so much
better than where we were before where
we had no color information or we were
relying solely on the retail information
that was messy or missing now we know
how much cover we have coverage we have
we know how likely it is that our
predictions are right and we can you
know consistently get these color
returns and then the next time we
iterate through we can go back and say
okay now we have this primary color name
maybe we also want a specific color so
we can go from from that previous slide
to this one where we get those specific
and again we're gonna start as simple as
possible so maybe that's something as
simple as taking a center crop of the
image so that we get the product and
just grabbing the RGB values that we get
clustering them so that we're joint we
are getting just the distinct colors
that we think are in the image and
that's really simple right like we
didn't do any deep learning no machine
learning as part of that we're really
just grabbing all the RGB values and
using very simple clustering album and
maybe that's a little messy right so
this is an example of literally just
doing that right so here's the original
image on the Left we have a center crop
in the middle and then on the right we
have a color plot where each RGB value
or we have one RGB value for each of
those clusters so potentially an RGB
value for each thing that we think is a
distinct color each one rep present in
the proportion that we saw it so this
one here is like a little over 50 the
one on the far right is there a little
over 50 percent and then we have a
darker one a lighter one so maybe that's
a little bit messy but we now have a
color name and a specific RGB value
right and that's a huge add on what we
had before we can demonstrate that value
as you move forward and then next
iteration go back clean it up and make
it less messy so their next step is to
make it tangible so this is a step that
I think a lot of people skip and a lot
of software engineering kind of gets for
free right so even if we haven't
completely finished us a project in
software engineering going back to my
experience as a mobile engineer maybe
you haven't finished a new app or you
haven't completely redesigned it but
maybe you've added a page maybe got a
button you can show that even if you're
doing backend work maybe you added a
feature that is then
present in the UI and you can
demonstrate that feature fairly easily
so there are cases where it's more
difficult but a lot of software
engineering I think kind of gets this
for free I'm so in data science we have
to do a little extra work to build this
oftentimes but I'm going to say that
it's worth it because I've seen the
reaction that you get I've been the the
biologist who didn't understand what the
project was or how to ask for features
when I didn't understand what was
happening and I've also been the
software engineer trying to encourage
other people to give me feedback and
seeing how much easier that is when you
have that tangible app to show people
and let them play with so my advice for
this if you can make an API I think it's
really the best starting point right
because it's not always super hard to do
there's a lot of tools out there to help
you build an API and then your users can
choose what they input see the output
they can start to see patterns and what
happens and really play with it with
what they would actually be inputting
themselves in the finished product also
bonus if you can make a visual endpoint
in the API so I have a co-worker who
always likes to you know take in the
input and return images so in this
example you would return those color
swatches rather than just the RGB value
and that way people can really put in
their own inputs and see the output
and it's very visual it's very engaging
and they can move forward with that also
demonstrating differences so in this
project there are different ways to pick
which area of the image you want to
analyze and really demonstrating that
and making it visual has really helped
people to understand how that works and
why they should choose one over the
other
so in this example we have a seed image
at the top we have an example where we
use image segmentation and again a color
plot of the RGB values that we get from
that image segmentation and then a
center crop and a color plot of what we
get from that Center crop image so
really making that visual showing them
the difference because when I first went
up and tried to explain like oh this is
why you would want to use image
segmentation over a Center crop or one
way or the other it's hard to visualize
what that end result is really going to
be if you don't show people examples
again we can demonstrate the steps that
we take right so even if you just
changed the way the pipeline works this
is one demonstration of one of my early
pipelines of this project so on the left
hand side we have the full initial seed
images then we have the center crops and
I did something called super pixel
segmentation which is where we go
through the image and join together as
one group RGB values that are similar
shade and next to each other so we're
trying to see what do we think are
distinct groups in this image and can we
treat them all as one group called a
super pixel and so this is a a marking
of where those outlines are and what we
thought was all one group then we have a
plot next to that where we took one RGB
value from each of those groupings and
then the one next to it is if we had
just clustered it initially and the
joint plot is if we then take that
single RGB value from each of the super
pixels and cluster those together so
that we're getting the distinct values
that we got from each group and then
showing those steps and making that
really visual can help people understand
you know what that really means the
steps you took what what is happening at
each of those stages and why you might
want to include them we can also show
latency right so as I talked about maybe
it is really valuable on certain
occasions to make your request a lot
faster right especially if you're it's
going to be used in real time or you're
doing it on a lot of data at once you
might want to increase the time so I
think a good way to display this is to
make it super visual right so this is a
latency graph of an early request and
here on the right we have if we had just
done clustering no none of that super
pixel segmentation we're just getting
all of the RGB values out of an image
and then clustering them and it took
almost 30 seconds like 29 seconds and
that's a huge wait time for people to
have to sit and wait and then here in
the middle we have if we just do that
super pixel segmentation how long it
takes for us to pull out those groups in
an image and then the blue on there on
the far left we see if we do one and
then the other so we're pulling out all
the RGB eyes from each group and then we
have to do clustering on a much smaller
set and that
takes much less time this is a very
visual way to show how much faster it's
really going to be right it's also nice
if you can demonstrate that like show
the request show how long it takes
beforehand and then show the request
afterwards and how much faster it really
is and then people can understand the
real time difference in that request
that they're making we can also show
data set creation so a huge part of data
science projects is creating a data set
so as part of this I had to go through
all these specific color names that we
have and map them to the 13 general
colors that I showed in the beginning
and this took forever right it's a lot
of manual data labeling and then it came
time to present and I'd spent most of
the time doing this data set labeling so
that's what I demoed right I showed
these products on the left I showed
their specific names I showed what
general color we had to map them to and
then I picked out some examples that I
thought were really difficult right that
were really hard for me to label that I
thought was in-between and so not only
is this demonstrating how hard it was to
build a data set but it's also
demonstrating the benefits of having
those specific names right like if we
can't categorize these into a more
general one we really need those
specific names to do it for us I also do
a lot of demoing of metrics so one time
I as part of this project I had to go
through send a bunch of product images
through Phoenix through the new project
get those mappings to the more general
names and then test them against
validation images that we already had
that had those general names assigned to
them and then I broke it up into exactly
what the discrepancies were right so you
have a bunch of them that are correct we
have some that have like cropping issues
so maybe we're pulling out the wrong
product and then we have some confusion
between certain categories of color but
then we also had some messy data right
so we also want to show that so we have
something like this where the label on
the image that are on the product that
we were given is orange Phoenix or our
project returned pink and so maybe we
can show something like this of our
actual specific name of peachy pink or
peach is correct and this
not necessarily a false label or a bad
label but just showing how this label
this data can be messy or confusing and
also an incorrect labeled one right so
we don't necessarily we didn't manually
label these validation images we don't
know if they're 100% correct
so really showing that our expectedly
the label that we had on this validation
image was green but our model gave it
black which I would argue is a better
for label for the primary color in this
item and I think a lot of people don't
understand why our metrics or our models
are so influenced by messy data so
something like showing this of you know
we're getting a low percent correct in
this certain area but a large portion of
that is because the labels we have are
incorrect and showing that demonstrating
that can really help to explain to other
people why it matters so much that our
data be clean alright so now we've
talked to a lot about what exactly we
want a demo I'm going to talk about the
demo itself so I think it's really
important especially since there's so
much confusion around data science to
start off with a problem statement of
exactly why your product is difficult so
this is the exact side I use in my one
of my early presentations of this
project of explaining why it's really
hard to get color from a product so as
an engineer it might seem super easy
right we already have our GB values in
the actual image why can't we just go in
and grab them and get the color for the
product and so what I really wanted to
demonstrate here was if you see this
item if we look at the top where the
ruffles are kind of in the light we get
this really light RGB value whereas we
look in the middle we get kind of a
middle blue RGB value that maybe is
representative of this dress but if we
look at the shadow we get this super
dark RGB value that I would argue as not
representative this dress and the thing
is we can't just take the average of all
these because what if this were a
striped dress what if there are multiple
colors in the image how are we going to
figure out which colors we're going to
consider real colors and which ones we
think start to shadow this can be a
really difficult product problem but
also for deep learning color is really
subjective so does anyone remember the
whole white gold blue black dress
who thinks this looks white and gold
raise of hands anyone no no okay who
thinks it looks blue and black whoever
thinks it looks like something
completely different okay yep I had a
friend tell me that it looks like golden
blue so I guess there's all kinds of
options right and this is kind of an
entertaining example but it also goes to
show how difficult it is to build a
robust data set if you're trying to
train a deep learning model or if you're
if you're trying to even confirm if what
you're doing is correct it can be really
difficult when that's such a subjective
opinion I went through a lot of products
where I wasn't sure what the color is so
I asked someone else and they gave me a
completely different color than the two
that I had been considering and really
demonstrating that and why this is such
a hard problem was really important
because I think it seems not necessarily
trivial but an easily solvable problem
from the get-go um I also can think it'd
be interesting to show not necessarily
competitors about what other people are
doing so this is not to bash on any
retailers but just to show how hard this
problem can really be I went to some
retailer websites and took screenshots
of things that they had labeled as
purple and so as you can see some of
these a purple a lot of them I would
argue are red or blue or even gray and
so it's not a very clean system even in
all ready production retail sites right
no one is necessarily doing this problem
super well already you might think maybe
purple is just really hard to classify
so I also included some images of red
which I think are okay but we still see
a lot of these examples of things that
maybe are a little brownish maybe are
completely brown in the belt maybe have
some red in them but might not be
primarily red I'm just showing that this
is a difficult problem that not everyone
is solving right so maybe our v1 is
actually better than what a lot of
people already have maybe one of the
iterations we're doing is actually
showing a value-add over what we're
competing against and what already
exists in the market and so this has
helped me a lot with getting
stakeholders on board with how long it
takes to build a data set and why it is
so important that we spend some
time on it I think there's a lot of
misunderstanding of you know why do you
need to do so much research development
why do we need to do so much testing in
data science why do we need to try out
so many different things why does it
take so long to build a data set right
why can't we there's a lot of outside
sources that can label data for us so
why can't we just contract them out
right if any one work with our figure
eight or even other data labeling
problems right a lot of times they do a
good job but a lot of times that's also
super messy and we have to spend a ton
of time cleaning it up to make sure that
it's actually usable and I think it can
be kind of confusing to other people why
exactly we have to spend so much time on
that and why we just can't move forward
and use the data that we already have
all right so the next step is iterate so
I think we've talked a little bit about
all of these steps how to move forward
how we're going to increase the value
each time and then we want to just go
through it and do it all again right so
we have our use case we have our overall
use case we have the value that we
currently have how are we going to add
incrementally more value each time go
through each step and repeat the whole
process over and over again and that way
with each iteration we're getting more
feedback more input and and just more
communication with the people who are
actually using the product all right so
now we have a stable ish product I hope
at least who knows what we're ready to
move into production but we're ready to
move it into production so what exactly
do we want to do beforehand
first of all I would save monitoring so
these are just very basic monitoring of
this project at the top we have an
uptime check that's just a binary one or
zero whether we're getting a response at
the bottom it's just a very basic
response time of the API for a request
and I know there's a lot of debate about
out there about who exactly should be in
charge of monitoring right so a lot of
companies have a system where the data
science team builds this model finishes
it they do some metrics they're ready to
send it into production and they kind of
throw it over the fence to an
engineering team and hope that the
engineering team cares enough to build
in the monitoring and make it production
ready I would argue that this is
something data science should
and that it helps us in a lot of ways to
do it and is worth the potentially
minimal time to put it into production
so first of all they don't make it into
production otherwise right I think we've
seen a lot of cases where data science
throws it over the fence and that's just
one more team they have to convince to
halt their priorities to work on ours
and that doesn't always work right an
engineering team might not have time to
put monitoring your project it might not
be on their roadmap it might get put on
the roadmap for months ahead of time and
then kind of forgotten about doesn't get
updated when needs to so us doing our
own monitoring really helps move that
into production also you're the one who
understands the service right the ones
who built it the one who understands it
and so we should be the ones to put in
that monitoring because we know what to
do if it breaks it also builds trust
right so we've talked this whole time
about how to convince other teams to
possibly set aside their priorities in
order to use these projects so if we
spend all that time convincing people
and working with them to make sure it's
exactly what they need and then we have
no idea when it breaks and we're relying
on them to come to us and say your
product isn't working so all of our
stuff is working they're not gonna want
to put that effort in to use our project
next time right whereas if we can be the
ones who say we know it's broken we're
working on fixing it they will rely on
us more in the future and be more
willing to work with us and use those
products in the future I think we heard
in the keynote yesterday right data
science projects debatably never end and
I think that this can help us a lot
right then you might have to move on to
a new project you might have to retrain
the model you might have to put
something new out and having these
monitors in place can make that a lot
more reliable so you feel okay moving
forward moving on to something else or
completely iterating through their
project again and you'll know if
something breaks and you need to go back
to it I'm also documenting it so this is
just a basic readme of exactly how to
use the product if you want to use it in
production but also includes if you need
to test it if you want to change
something if you want to add a feature
and you want to test it on your own
it's all the instructions that you need
in order to do that and I think this is
a really important part of having that
documentation in place of how to test it
how to use it how it all works but then
also where to look if it breaks right so
we also have a document of these
monitors go off these alerts go off
something's not working where should you
look in each project to fix it or who
should you contact if you're not sure
and that's hugely important part of this
and goes back to you know building that
trust and making your project
maintainable even if you have to move
forward to something else and again you
might forget I think we've all been in
that situation where we go back to a
piece of our own code or something we've
built years ago even months ago and we
don't remember how a part of it worked
so having this documentation in there
helps other people but also helps you
when you go back to your project all
right
so overall recap of this project right
we can keep up engagement from our
stakeholders and our users we're
continually reminding them we're also
getting feedback from them at each
juncture so they can give us those
feature needs they get to really play
with the application and give direct
feedback on ok I like this part I would
rather have this part I need to change
this section or this structure and that
helps keep them engaged make sure it's
what they really want but make sure it's
they're also excited about it and still
ready to use it we get to iterate faster
right so if we put out one of these
iterations and they say oh actually this
isn't the format I want it in I
definitely had that experience as a
software engineer where I built an app
exactly based on how someone said they
wanted it they play with it they
realized they needed something different
but if you've meeting with them every
two weeks every month every quarter
whatever it is then you can directly go
back and change that rather than seeing
that six months down the line and
realizing as a decision you made at the
very beginning doesn't work for them
right so we're much faster iteration we
get to do this in sections we can change
things quickly based on what they say
also stakeholder understanding so the
people that are working with us the
people that are investing us maybe your
managers the executives they're
understanding why what you're doing is
taking a long time they're understanding
why you need the resources you're asking
for because you're constantly demoing
how you're using those resources even if
it's not a finished product
yeah so this is a little bit of future
reading I talked a little bit about
metrics and one of my co-workers wrote a
blog post on it that I think is really
cool this is a future reading about the
13% production if you want to lead it a
little more about that and other
people's opinions on it I'm also a huge
thank you to all these people and the
generally the data science team is
chopped runner they've been very helpful
and supportive throughout this whole
process so I really appreciate it thanks
one minute
all right speed question okay yeah so
not on this project specifically yet but
I would advise doing that I think
there's a couple things that you should
monitor uptime I mean the the basics
that I showed but also if you know your
inputs drastically change or your
outputs drastically change and then I
think something like if people shop for
that based on what you do might not
necessarily be a data science problem it
depends on how the company structured
but we don't necessarily have access to
that live like who clicked on what
button so whoever has access to that
data I definitely recommend adding
monitoring into that we do a specific a
B testing to get that information so
we'll you know hold out a section where
we don't show this new method we'll give
a section where we do show this new
method and see do more people click on
the recommendations that have the new
specific color information versus the
old color information if you if that is
something you can put into monitoring
and make that automatic instead of like
a manual process I 100% recommend that I
do know that it is more difficult on
certain projects yeah oh yeah I also
have Phoenix stickers so if anyone would
like a takeaway from the talk please
come grab a sticker
you
[Applause]